Joel said uh we're doing the script No
Country for Old Men I just read the book
I said well aren't you going to direct
and they said well we might I said I'll
never talk to you again if you don't
direct it
.
Blick let's talk about this for a minute
why
I don't think you should move the camera
unless you've got a very important
reason for doing so I'm in 1917 it was
really useful because you're telling a
story in a very particular way and it's
a real time story and you're following
basically one character it worked it
immersed the audience within this in
this story
you know we had to design basically the
shot
in our heads and on a diagram before the
set could be built before the trenches
could be darker because everything had
to be built to the actual action at the
time the action would take a time that
the dialogue would take with two guys
walking at a certain speed and we went
to Aryan said you know we were going to
do this film so I really like to shoot
it on the LF but I can't do it on the
studio LF I mean it's not as heavy as a
535 maybe you know film camera but it's
still kind of too heavy to run on a
lightweight gimbal sorry we said to
Harry well oh if you can't do it there
are some other cameras that we could use
and Harry said well
oh my well we thought about making one
but not for a few years and I said well
it's only it's next year
they said okay we we promise you we can
get you two prototypes
it was a trick that I'd done on Jarhead
actually leaving a set of Lights in shot
and then just replacing those lights
with a fire element the night scenes
under the oil fires we basically shot
them on stage at Universal we had the
two big stages with the door open in the
middle and basically filled it with kind
of sand dunes and then I lit that
entirely with household bulbs you get in
my Home Depot and I had them on you know
chasing dimmers and so they gave a sort
of flicker so when we came to do 1917
and the burning church
I thought well okay I need to like 360
but this time I need to light a huge
space because a schofield's journey is
enormous really running that's quite a
long sort of old trip and there were
very specific places where the light
needed to be so I figured to
make the biggest pile of Lights I've
ever done I could just sort of balance
each light in this huge rig and you know
punch it out a little bit where I needed
a bit more of a hot spot or soften it
all down that was really very controlled
prisoners
tell me where they are
that was the first film I did with Denny
and I think some of it we storyboarded
but I know Danny and I spent
quite a while talking through the script
talking about Concepts and ideas and
just the feel of the thing which uh that
sort of period I think is invaluable and
I love it you know then he calls it the
the one time you can dream because as
soon as you get to the production and
reality hits and everything's
compromised I mean whatever you think of
anything you've ever done you look at it
and you know it's a compromise
the trick was to get the rain and to get
the rig on the car and to get the town
where they're driving through the town
and get the number of vehicles not only
stunt vehicles but actually just local
people to turn up with their cars that
was a big effort that was the last day
of shooting in fact and it took to the
end of the shoot
for us I say us for Danny and I really
to get friendly to get production to
sign off on it on on that number of cars
and that and control that street luckily
it was a small town street and it wasn't
going to be very busy late at night I
couldn't light it there's no way you
could put lights in it so I needed the
street lights to work you know the shops
to be lit that lent to leave the lights
on in certain times and you know so
there's all those things you have to
work out we were both very glad at the
end we actually managed to do it because
there was some doubt about it for a
while we hereby Paul Dino a few months
ago and he was really gushing about the
energy that team deacons had that there
was this quiet professionalism we've
worked very much with the same core
people you know my first assistant Andy
Harris I mean I worked with since doing
Fargo on every movie I every movie Mitch
Lillian the key grip um you know early
reader gaffer I've worked with many many
times times since Sid and Nancy they all
know the kind of set I like which is
quiet and I I you know I'm always behind
the camera they know that they have more
responsibility because I am at the
camera so they have to be attentive to
things that might change rather than
having me go and try and find where they
are to get something else done you know
so it's a very very tight group of
people it's nice to hear somebody like
pull down and say that I think one of
the cinematographer's main
responsibilities is to create a set that
is
it's in inviting it's a safe place for
an actor to do what they have to do
because if you didn't have the
performance you wouldn't have anything
in most films you owe it to them really
and I think that's really important I
mean I'm kind of a nervous person
especially on on a movie set but I was
nervous I am as I am you've got to
understand and actors are as well and
and they're the ones kind of putting
themselves on the line on the screen
really
Redemption
because if you do
what did you say 35
000 35
000 all of it all of it every penny
you better start making sense if you
want to keep all that money give it to
your wife I was the American Society of
cinematographers Clubhouse one time in
there some of my heroes that this
obviously with years ago talking about
this film and saying yeah it was really
well shot but you know it's much easier
when you just use natural light they
didn't realize but I mean the whole cell
block is a set that's built inside a
warehouse yeah we shot in a real prison
but only the exteriors and the messel
was a real prison and some corridors and
to do that I had to have every
every HMI that my gaffer Bill O'Leary
could get hold of in America in the
states we had in Mansfield lighting that
location the daylight because we were
shooting a 12-hour day you could maybe
shoot two or three hours with natural
light in some of those rooms but you'd
have to make sure it was a nice day you
don't want to over dramatize it I mean
the shot of timus when he escapes when
he's standing looking up the Heavens
with his arms out and the rain I mean
that's as dramatic as it gets maybe
that's a little too dramatic as well but
so there was a huge amount of lighting
in it and I thought it was kind of
flattering when they said they they
didn't feel there was any lighting
involved
sicario
[Music]
well that was like okay so it's getting
dark so how are they gonna see and how
are we gonna see how's the audience
gonna see well I read this it was Danny
well it's all very well but if you want
the audience to see anything that's
going to be a cheat and then he said
well what if everything is seen through
their assisted Vision And I said Okay
well I've done night vision enough I did
it in a film called courage Under Fire
quite a lot of it but the problem is
then how do you just differentiate
between the characters points of view
then he said yeah it'll be all right we
need two different systems my wife and I
James and I we kind of were doing
research on this and and found this
company called FLIR who were doing kind
of high-end infrared imagery and they
lent us a camera that we could um
experiment with so you get a very
different image like that from you know
what is basically a heat sensor as
opposed to something that is an image
intensifier that is actually just taking
the Starlight or whatever and just put
the hell out of it one shot we we shot
during the test
which was following somebody as they
were going down the steps into the
tunnel a prop guy heated up the soles of
their shoes so they're really hot so the
beginning of the shot they're walking
and it's like really you see these
Footprints really bright and by the time
they get to the bottom of stairs it's
faded away you know it's a really
interesting trick there's a shot in the
film like that but it's never held long
enough that you see the footprints
disappear but my favorite scene in the
film probably is in the kitchen it's
just a simple two-hander between Emily
and Benicio
[Applause]
I need you to sign this piece of paper
it basically says that everything we did
was done by the book
originally that was like a few pages of
dialogue Benicio said do we really need
this I had a long long rehearsal time
stripping it down to the Bare Essentials
and I thought that was just fantastic I
really enjoyed that at the end of all
this all the rest of the stuff that's
gone on you get to that point and it's
like okay but I know it was really good
Big Lebowski
[Music]
yeah it was very much Joel and Ethan you
know their idea I mean we talked it
through I mean we talk about little
things about how you do the stars and
the backing you know which I did it all
with like 3M front projection material
and cut it up stuff like that you know I
remember when the Wardrobe was designed
and they've got these big kind of
bowling kind of hat things around them
and it was really awkward but it
actually was kind of interesting the way
they worked and everything you know and
then you find a way of tracking down the
the bowling alley and one time we used
this little remote car with a camera
rigged on it but another time
Bruce having my um Dolly group said I'll
get a 30-foot pipe we'll put the camera
at the end of it and I'll just push it
down so the shot going under the legs of
the girls down there it's just the
camera on a little soft pad and my dolly
grips got this long metal pipe and he's
just pushing it down the middle and it's
really low Tech but it's kind of fun we
commit your final Mordor remains
to the bosom of the Pacific Ocean
which you love so well
good night sweet prince
we were standing down on the hillside
down and Pedro and uh
and it just happened that it was so
windy they threw the ashes out of the
French roast can French roast which is
something we talked about as being kind
of funny anyway the ash comes out and it
disappears which is fine but I looked
around and my assistant was completely
covered in them so was I
oh dude I'm sorry
that's how I remember things like that
was kind of funny I kind of love all
those little challenges yeah
No Country For Old Man
call it
Colin yes
we're hot just got it
well we need to know what we're calling
it for here you need to call it I can't
call it for you
you wouldn't be fair I didn't put
nothing up yes you're dead you've been
putting it up your whole life you just
didn't know it
the thing about Gerald and Ethan they
love
getting into different kind of Worlds
you know they kind of just move around
in different genres don't they really
interesting way but they're very
prepared you know spend a lot of time
talking about it doing drawings
storyboarding studying locations you
talk about the night sequence going into
the river
they were very very specific locations
and the whole sequences split up the
trucks are where the drug bust goes
wrong is one location and then running
to the river is about a couple of miles
away from that so it was you know like
any film it's a sort of jigsaws how you
sort of schedule things but it was
really important for this because it
wasn't a huge amount of money it wasn't
a hugely big budget film one of the
things that early on that Joel and Ethan
said when we're shooting this just be
aware we're not going to have any music
on it they knew right at the start well
before we started shooting
the only sound would be natural sounds
so that impacts like okay when do you
have dust going through or where do you
have kind of grass so you can feel a
wind and have that wind noise and like
the peanut wrapper in the gas station
you know the packet just going
again everything's storyboarded in
advance even though sometimes we would
change change things fairly dramatically
on set
yes
my gaffer Krishna politano and I spent
many nights many days and then nights as
well going to that town and saying well
we were going to put lights and how we
were going to rig Street lamps and which
street lamps we didn't want on because
it was kind of too flat with them on and
which ones would be the key sources you
know over I think it was two weeks they
cabled the rooftops and put not a lot of
lights but a little lights in very
specific places we knew if we were in
the truck looking out the window those
lights had to be on and then we wanted
this shop to stay open or we wanted to
put some fluorescent tubes above the
shop you know there's still things that
happened on the day and you just find oh
well that light doesn't work but I could
put one here and that'll be really
interesting you know it's partly
creative and trying to get in the heads
of the directors but getting the heads
of the characters as well and reflect
the characters and the story going on in
front of you but it's also a technical
challenge so you sort of break it down
into all the
aspects that you need to deal with and
there's one shot
where Tommy Lee goes back to the motel
room
he's standing in the doorway and his
truck is outside and his Shadows playing
on the wall and it's kind of this
fractured kind of Shadow and there's a
mirror with another bit of fractured
light you know usually I don't use two
lights I have two Shadows I mean because
it's not really real but at this point
it just seemed right and that's how you
try and express something that's going
on with the character and within the
scene
Skyfall
who doesn't appreciate the occasional
twists Mr Bond
James Bond and first I heard about Sam
doing a bomb movie he called me up
and he said don't put a phone down but I
I'm gonna do the next James Bond and I
think I've probably said something why
wouldn't I put the phone down
he said we're just going to approach it
it's just a film it's nothing to you
know look at it just as a film like
we've done already Jarhead or
Revolutionary Road and it's just it's a
film it's about a character it's about
an aging spy who's the world's passing
him by you know can he still compete and
it's about those sort of things we
weren't making
a Bond movie that that's the way I saw
it
single camera you know I like to operate
so I operated certain sequences we had
11 cameras you do on when you have big
stunts in action but for the most part
it was very controlled and very
considered and like any other movie and
you know if it had been multiple cameras
and dozens of units I I wouldn't I
wouldn't have taken it but um Sam said
no we're gonna we'll concentrate it so
it's it's as much a character study as
it is an action movie that's that's what
drew me in at one point we discussed
about the attack coming off the water
you know these guys in dinghies at night
coming and the forest behind the castle
going on firing it but you do that on a
real location I mean with oh
you know the frozen lake is CG in the
background and when the building's on
fire we shot some of it on this location
with a brilliantly um controlled burn of
the set and then we recreated that in a
similar way as doing the church in in
1917 we recreate that on stage with a
big light bank which was replaced with
elements that which are of the house
burning on on location the ice was fake
ice the break in the ice was helped with
CG but we shot underwater shots on a
tank but again you kind of you you know
what the wish list is and you sort of
break it down into what shots you can do
and you know as much as possible you do
it in camera you know
Saga
I think I'm drawn to Desolation although
it's my still photographs of desolated
English Seaside or the American West
I'm not very good at shooting crowds I
like lonely people in big spaces I guess
so Fargo is good for me
you're the owner here Mr lundegaard now
executive sales manager well you can
help me my name is Marge Gunderson my
father-in-law he's the owner
uh-huh well I'm a police officer from up
Brainerd investigating some malfeasance
and I was just wondering if you'd had
any new vehicles stolen off the lot in
the past couple of weeks
we didn't get any snow that year that
was a real frustration one day we would
shoot part of the scene in one location
during the day the snow would melt and
then we would have to go like another 20
miles north to get another place that
could match and shoot there and we were
it was funny some of the parking lot
shots it's totally created snow so the
effects team will work all night snowing
new airport parking lot and the one
outside the main office building can you
even name all the movies that you worked
on with your own Brothers ah but I'm
thinking Fargo
serious man Intolerable Cruelty Big
Lebowski I'm losing track now yeah I see
no country
assassination of Jesse James by the
coward Robert Ford
open that safe
you know I'm very lucky doing a western
like that it's more like a tone poem in
a way it's a kind of memory it's I don't
know if you read the book a wonderful
book The the film's based on it it's
wonderful it's pure poetry
[Music]
there are a few existing photographs of
Jesse James especially who won at one at
his death in the morgue or whatever that
vignette is a old box camera and it's
vignetting and Andrew and I talked about
it a lot and he said I think that would
be a really interesting way to come in
and out of sequences and give it a
slightly strange sort of distance feel
we got feedback from
certain people
saying can you shoot it without with a
normal lens because we don't know about
this we don't like it so I think we kind
of pull back a little bit seeing the
Final Cut I remember talking to Andrew
and we both said we should have used it
a little more because there's other
places it could have
built the transition between sequences
and that's what it was really about
our country down
mine just Leon a director I mean justly
no I would love to I did see the longer
cut because I saw an edit we shot a lot
of what happened after the film ends we
shot what happens to Frank James which
is really interesting because he had a a
farm up in Maine or somewhere up there
he used to take tourists around his farm
and charge them for looking at his
Farmhouse and stuff it's like gangster
tourism or whatever you know what I mean
it's like I thought that was really
interesting and you just in the film
there was more things with Ford before
he shot his relationship with this woman
in this town of creed up in the Rockies
and this woman commits suicide jumps off
a bridge I mean it's all true it's all
what actually happened and I'm a sucker
for true stories that are so strange and
tell you so much about that period and
those characters and that life that they
had I think it's so good I could have
done with the other hour you know and it
wouldn't have made any more money or
lost any more money so why the hell you
know
Empire of light
the film for me when I first read the
script was very much about a small world
a character who's lonely but she gets
Solace and comfort from the friends
around her and most of her friends and
most of the people she sees every day or
in the cinema the people that she works
with in the cinema the people of their
supporter they know her problem and they
support her so I for me the film's about
Community it's not about the wonders of
movie making all that rubbish it's it's
really about this one Woman's World and
felt much more of a film that needed to
be quiet and sort of observational in a
way and the camera was just kind of
observing and allowing the characters to
to be within the frame so when do we you
know open up
um
20 minutes
what's up there I'll public out loud can
I have a look oh I'm not sure go on
please
the film required a a upstairs abandoned
Ballroom an abandoned part of the cinema
and that's what Dreamland provided so we
were lucky to find that really it was
strange because the lobby at Dreamland
is kind of very small and it's got a low
ceiling and it's got no staircase or
anything and and that script required
something a little bit more
you know you enter this space and there
it is a Lobby and a staircase and the
cinema is going on so the solution we
had was actually building a set on a
space facing the Promenade to marry it
with what would be the view out of the
location I used a lot of LEDs you know
obviously
they like changes you know and a lot of
the action takes place inside and
outside the lobby but it's actually open
to the environment so I needed some way
of being able to control the light level
on the inside against the outside not
only in terms of intensity but also
color balance because at the end of the
day light's getting Bluer and all the
rest of it and the other reason was you
build them into a set like that and if
you use it you know traditional tungsten
lights they get incredibly hot and that
would have been kind of crazy especially
with us shooting in the winter the glass
doors hot inside cold outside that's
recipe for a lot of Badness
Blade Runner 2049
[Music]
got her name
officer KD 6-3 that's not a name
serial number
all right
Joe
what do you want Joe I love sci-fi one
of my favorite films is tarkovsky
Solaris but I like that kind of sci-fi I
like something that feels kind of real I
don't like science fantasy but you know
the approach is different a kind of
color scheme of Blade Runner the kind of
world you're creating and you know if we
hold this shot it's getting like Andre
tarkovsky or Melville or whoever or
bresson if we hold this shot a bit
longer
maybe it'll mean something else maybe
the audience go why are we holding this
shot what's going to happen you build
attention through the use of the shot
the frame and just little camera
movements uh Denny's a master of that I
mean again it's all went all started
really with conversations we had in
pre-production and a lot of things just
develop they start as little things and
then develop and then you find how we're
going to do it technically you know the
sequence of the Holograms with the Elvis
singing and it's like a futuristic Las
Vegas maybe it's not futurist I haven't
been to Vegas for a while maybe it's
like that now and the idea it's all kind
of gone wrong so it's kind of this
confusion of different people and
different ideas but you you figure out
how you're going to do it one of the big
things about that was actually well how
are we going to shoot it we want this
big space but we can't afford the set so
I suppose just do it in black as I said
we just put black drapes up around it
couldn't have been cheaper so we figured
out well this whole I figured out okay I
did yeah I figured out this whole uh
rock and roll kind of lighting scheme I
did it with a company in Budapest who
actually do rock and roll and they had
these lights and we worked together and
programmed it all in so we had this
whole sequence of lighting different
lighting that goes with the different
characters that appear on stage and
Elvis had his own spot so it's a
technical challenge I'd never done it
before in such a complicated way it was
great it was great fun doing it yeah